non ma fille qu'est ce qu'un des stars
manifestent aujourd'hui contre la télé
poubelle sauf quoi de voir manifester
comme ça évidemment ça fait plaisir de
voir patrick sébastien qui rend ce jour
aucun télévision je vois pas dans le
vide comme en connaissent et les raisons
de son départ donc manifeste contre les
émissions les nouvelles émissions qui se
qualifie de télé-poubelle genre perdu de
vue et au train oui je pense qu'ils
doivent horizon puisque le de soutenir
monsieur ghosn et patrick est un
monsieur qui est très peiné de mon
départ à tf1 merci mais j'espère que ça
se passera bien pour vous vous avez
quand même un contre un message de
soutien à peu de sébastien
[Musique]
et si je lui dis si vous souhaitez qui
reste à la télé dit lui qua non j'essaie
de claques
c'est cool tu feras la place pour au
fait de voir partir de tf1 ça me fait de
la peine
il devrait pas parce qu'elles sont
molles ces émissions sont très agréables
à voir
il ya de bons acteurs et limites surtout
très bien il offense une imitation
pardon j'ai dit aux passionnés mutation
au pas aubade dans les chaussettes
le talent est là la raison pour laquelle
il est
c'est pas moi c'est toutes ces émissions
d'aujourd'hui quoi maintenant moi je
peux plus continuer comme ça qu'il faut
que je fasse autre chose parce que j'en
ai marre
pourtant cette basse quand vous êtes
quelqu'un non aujourd'hui c'est plus
qu'une merde hein ça fait de la peine
mois le pacte qui quitte tf1
merci merci c'est sympa merci qui
réfléchit et or audiovisuel attend dé
lui c'est pas un intellectuel c'est un
animateur il a pas compris deux mots de
tout ce que vous devez dire auront le
souci de faire semblant de reconnaître
les caricatures d'intellectuels pour
commencer celle les nerfs quand les lui
simplement je ne parle jamais simplement
je parle aux oiseaux et je parle courbin
on trouve pas qu'il y ait enfin sa juste
place
peut-être ne sait pas par moi de juger
moi je regarde pas beaucoup la télé dont
vous dirait de refermer le couvercle de
la médiocrité avec moi non non non c'est
tentant ouais bah ouais mais il faut
faire mal couverts sur les gens comme ça
dans une poubelle on les sort de la
poubelle ouais je n'ai d'yeux
les poubelles le but de merde
non merci
m
bruxelles voit le temps tu vois tant que
tu auras ça quand tu auras l'humour
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est bien ça fait
tout on peut tous passé il faut arrêter
avec la télé poubelle je suis patient
colère que saint germain attend ce qui
est dramatique c'est que telle et telle
mais l'ex-président tellement drôle tu
as un avis et un avis sur un truc tu dis
vrai pardon monsieur je pense que tout
de suite c'est pourtant ça tire de
partout on applaudit laurent baffie
encore une fois pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou